mais je voulais me tourner avant la
pause vers yann moix qui occupe une
position intermédiaire elle a émis
chroniqueur mythe et moi parce que vous
avez témoigné dans un livre d'une
enfance dur d'une enfance maltraitée
moi j'ai lu votre livre que j'ai
beaucoup aimé et je me pose la même
question que pour hakan si à l'époque
les conditions déjà très dur que vous
décrivez avait été encore aggravée par
le confinement
je ne sais pas ce que vous seriez devenu
à dire plusieurs choses eric la première
chose que j'aimerais dire c'est qu'il
nous a pas échappé que lorsque j'ai
sorti ce livre un écran de fumée s'est
fait hacker toute une polémique qui
étaient déclenchées contre moi pourquoi
qu'on ne parle pas du sujet en question
car à sept ce livre qui aurait dû faire
un scandale pour ses vraies raisons
tap les enfants tyranniser les enfants
maltraités les enfants torturés
on s'est arrangé in fine et pour ne
jamais parler de ce problème
moi je pense que frapper un enfant c'est
un crime contre l'humanité et je vais
vous dire pourquoi ça doit être
imprescriptible
parce qu'un enfant ça ne peut pas aller
manifester un enfant ça ne peut pas
aller au poste de police
un enfant ne sait pas que les droits
existent un enfant pense que ce qu'on
vit fait est normal
un enfant n'a pas de référentiel moi mes
parents ma tâche et et il me fouetter
avec des rallonges électriques pendant
des heures ma mère ricanait on faisait
manger des excréments
on m'a laissé nu pendant des heures par
moins 3 ou un 4 dehors en slip ça
rappelle des moments de l'histoire je
n'hésite pas à comparer que ce soit un
déporté ou un juif qui soit brutalisé
par un tortionnaire de la gestapo
aucun enfant de 6 ans là je parle
d'autres enfants que moi j'en ai
rencontré vous savez depuis que j'ai
sorti ce livre qui sont toute la journée
brûlé à vif qui sont fêtés avec auquel
on rajoute des celle du citron du sel
sur la plaie je suis absolument désolé
ça rappelle l'imprescriptibilité des
crimes les pires de notre histoire
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
quand je vois le livre d'hakan quand je
vois le visage d'hakan sur son livre sur
la couverture
ça me fait penser à cette phrase du
guitry de quel droit le père de mozart
frappe et il mozart qu'on voit ce visage
si intelligent aussi vif à qui on
donnerait le l'avenir en raison on lui
offrirait l'avenir sur un plateau parce
que quand je dis crimes contre
l'humanité l'humanité c'est l'avenir et
l'enfant
c'est l'avenir de l'humanité c'est
l'avenir de l'homme et son titre qui est
extraordinaire l'enfant mal placé 1
fonds battu martyrisé est un enfant qui
ne trouve jamais sa place
il est toujours là où il ne doit pas
être et je terminerai eric ça me fait
penser un livre que j'aime beaucoup et
j'encourage tous les auditeurs les
téléspectateurs à le lire c'est voyage
au bout de la nuit ou le faire ni en ces
lignes un passage extraordinaire barre
des menus est sur un bateau il va en
afrique et tout d'un coup il se fait un
coup de paranoïa absolue il a
l'impression et c'est le cas que tous
les passagers veulent eux jeté par
dessus bord parce qu'il n'a pas de quoi
payer et il pense que c'est un passager
clandestin
il ya cette phrase de céline parce que
bardamu doit se cacher il doit se terrer
à chaque fois il ya cette phrase de
céline qui est il faut pourtant bien
être quelque part
au bout d'un moment ils ne trouvent plus
de cachette et l'enfant maltraité
l'enfant martyrisé est un enfant qui ne
trouve pas sa place qui ne trouvent plus
de cachette et là où karim a raison
c'est que quand vous avez le
tortionnaire toute la journée avec vous
l'enfant est à sa merci
24 heures sur 24 l'enfant ne trouve plus
de cachette et l'endroit la liberté la
respiration la vitalité
ça s'appelle l'école ne comprendrais
jamais marrant à des géniteurs les
salopards qui m'ont mis au monde ne sont
que des géniteurs biologique et mes
parents ce sont mes professeurs
ça c'est une belle parole un bel hommage
au professeur mais est ce que vous
pensez qu'on devrait donc tenir compte
de ces situations qui ont l'air très
nombreuses canton d'hesdin drari c'est à
dire que il a comparé aux dégâts du que
vides le des dégâts faits sur les
psychologie humaine en ce moment sont
beaucoup plus grave c'est pour ça que
tout à l'heure je me suis permis sans
remettre en question la dignité et la
terre et que j'ai pour le pour leur
demandant d assurer comme telle dès
maintenant il n'a pas pris comme tel
parce que à force de faire un effet zoom
sur les dégâts dus qu'aux vide on ne
voit rien d'autre si vous voulez on est
aveuglé par une cible c'est à dire que
quelqu'un regarde pousser une pâquerette
et y aurait une guerre nucléaire tout
autour ou l' inverse
mais si vous voulez à tort d'être
aveuglé par une focale qui est toujours
la même on ne voit pas les déflagrations
qui sont faites sur les cerveaux sur les
enfants sur les femmes car là aussi je
suis plein alain presque tout le monde
et voir le monde et paysager que
d'efforts s'octroie le droit d'anéantir
des faibles c'est-à-dire des [ __ ] je
pense
que les dégâts sont à prendre en compte
et là où je rejoins karim à 1000% c'est
qu'on ne veut pas le voir et on le sait